I have so many thoughts I have so many
things I want to say what a bizarre
moment it's so weird to me like what
goes viral and what doesn't Liv Morgan
sets the record straight about that
Viral moment at Madison Square Garden
another top star is where the Road to
WrestleMania Super Show comes to the
Garden on Sunday March 12th it's so
weird that it just spread the way that
it did but it was not what it seemed the
WWE star was taking in Tuesday night's
game minding her own business when she
went viral for appearing to be
completely uninterested in the man who
was talking to her yeah the moment
became an instant hit online with people
joking that it was a living meme of a
mansplaining well Liv appeared on the
bump on Wednesday to weigh in on the
whole thing explaining that the man next
to her wasn't some random Knicks fan
trying to woo her but a WWE Live event
exec we had no idea that we were even
being filmed we had no idea that the
camera on us which doesn't excuse
anything he's incredible he was
explaining something to me and I was
watching the game and I was like
listening but I was also kind of deep in
my head thinking my own thoughts I was
just like dude you know kind of like in
my own world I'm just so unaware that
this was being filmed another top Stars
where the Road to WrestleMania Super
Show well Liv wasn't unaware for long
she says her phone blew up after the
moment aired I just see this footage and
I just was like
I was like oh my gosh Dustin I'm so
sorry and um he's been such a great
sport about it but
um yeah I don't know is the most bizarre
weirdest thing and while the whole thing
may have been bizarre Liv says women
don't have to apologize for ignoring men
it was so weird but also
um let's say I was ignoring him it is
woman's History Month
we'd love to see a strong woman in and
out of the ridge from Liv to Nikki and
Brie Bella we're very very passionate
that's how we do it to Dwayne The Rock
Johnson's daughter Simone who's taking
up the family business very very proud
of her she is fiercely independent it's
very important for her to make her own
way Blaze her own trail and I'm here
watching and supporting happy women's
History Month to these Fearless females
[Music]
foreign